rappel on est venu nous chercher durant
la nuit conduiront au bateau binetruy
tron avait 8 ans quand il a fui le
vietnam avec son frère de 11 ans et sa
tante à bord de cette petite embarcation
de fortune conçus pour naviguer sur des
rizières
après la chute de saïgon le 30 avril
1975 tout le sud du vietnam est envahi
par la famine
voilà chaque repas préparé leur famille
avec son épouse kim a quelque chose de
réconfortant mais la vie n'a pas
toujours été aussi dos ma jeunesse je
déjeunais avec une banane je dînais avec
une banane et jeux super parfois avec
une banane fait depuis trente cinq ans
que chute au canada j'ai pas mangé une
scène banale chiffrable mais ça ça
marqué cette époque après guerre pour
moi
entassés contre le moteur parmi une
trentaine d'inconnus sans gilet de
sauvetage
il se rappelle que c'était le prix de la
liberté pour fuir le régime communiste
et la pauvreté
on a 25 % de chances de chauffer reprend
par les autorités un autre 25 % que tu
pouvais coulé en mer causé tempête puis
un autre 25 % les pirates allende et
attendait au large aussi fait que
finalement
après une chance sur quatre la pouvoir
s'en sortir de cette aventure
cette longue journée et six longues
nuits ont passé avant qu'un bateau alma
le cap anamur ne repèrent leurs
embarcations sur son écran radar
un sauvetage dans les conditions
difficiles en mer nous avons eu de la
chance
quinze minutes après que tout le monde
soit monté à bord en sécurité une
violente tempête s'est levée
notre embarcation aurait coulé à 8 ans
minh tri son frère et sa tante sont
passés à quelques minutes de se noyer en
pleine tempête le père de minuteries qui
connaissent elles risquent affirment que
ces enfants n'étaient pas plus en
sécurité en restant vietnam
j'avais deux choix les laisser
s'enfoncer dans la misère ou jeu tentait
le tout pour le tout pour les envoyer là
où il aurait un avenir meilleur après le
sauvetage in extremis du cap anamur minh
triêt a passé sept mois dans un camp de
réfugiés sur l'île de galan en indonésie
lui son frère devait survivre tous les
jours avec mes cousins je faisais là
prennent 10 km de marche la balle et
faire la pêche avec lui monté sur
falaise redescendre à la plage pour
aller pêcher
puis je revendais le poisson dans les
baraques j'étais capable sur l'île de me
payer un coca cola c'était un luxe
suprême pour un petit jeune de se payer
un petit gramme des raisins ou une pomme
à l'époque c'est en janvier 1995 entre
son frère et sa tante arrives tu à
montréal sur la base militaire de
longue-pointe sa vie au canada commence
officiellement 13 longues années l'ont
séparé de sa famille sans qu'il puisse
voir ses parents il a donc étudié puis
sept inscrits en techniques policières
pour pouvoir parrainer sa famille qui
fondent leur espoir en lui
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
rentré aussi dans la presse
pour accélérer le processus parce que
trois en technique policière me
permettait d'avoir peut-être une
promesse d'embauché puis prouver au
gouvernement que j'ai un revenu pour les
faire venir rapidement
c'est la raison pour laquelle en vrille
après peu de gens qui savent aujourd'hui
minh tri et commandant la division du
crime organisé au spvm son travail lui
permet de redonner à la société qui l'a
accueilli l'an trop traité enquêteur
principal durant la commission
charbonneau et participez à la mise en
place du bureau de l'inspecteur général
de montréal
son grand frère lui est devenu ingénieur
chez hydro québec
son regard est rempli de fierté quand il
est accompagné de sa femme et leurs
enfants
sa fille a exactement le même âge qu'il
avait lors de la traversée en haute mer
qui a changé le cours de son destin
alaoui talent elle a voyagé elle n'a
jamais connu de misère ma fille et moi
huit ans je marchais 10 km par jour
sans mes parents et j'ai essayé de
vendre le poisson aux adultes le soir à
200 poissons parce que j'avais pas de
frigidaires puis les adultes savaient
très bien si je vendais pas le poisson
c'était je pourrais pas le conserver
il souhaite que son histoire de survie
démontre que les migrants qui fuient la
misère au péril de leur vie peuvent
enrichir la société à leur façon